I mean you know the emoji with the big
ol eyes yeah that's that's me yeah that
is a little bit of the spike that taraji
be incident serving up tomorrow night on
Empire but the drama she teaches as
cookie is nothing compared to what she
has overcome in real life and taraji
opened up the pages of her new memoir to
her Jennifer Paris you talk about your
first memory in the book of your father
trying to kidnap you
my father he was homeless he served in
the military he was a police officer he
battled with his demons just like all
humans do but my father didn't hide it
from me
taraji was just four years old when her
dad tried to kidnap her she says she was
caught in the middle of an abusive
marriage and divorce as he wanted to
spend time with her but today Dhiraj
he's not bitter a lot of cookie comes
from my father a lot of the one-line
zingers are things that my dad would say
boy back I know what I'm doing I've been
doing it longer than you what he taught
me was that in life you're gonna fall
get back up and get that cop is exactly
what taraji did when she was 23 and
college pregnant and the father of her
baby punched her in the face knowing
that if he abused her once he'd do it
again taraji got out you can find
yourself in any bad situation in life
guess who it is up to the kid out of it
you yep that's it if you're not chained
to a wall and no one has a gun to your
head saying if you walk-ons almost shoot
you where's the power you have the power
but I saw having a baby in colleges you
know what I got a mouth to feed now I
gotta make my dreams come true right now
taraji attended Howard University where
her baby Marcel who is now 22
transferred last year he doesn't
remember all of the bad times like when
we were poor you grow eating all of the
little did you ever think about having
more children
I don't know time is actually ticking so
it might be fun for me
Oh leave it really really yeah